Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend.
Ich bin heute die DINSA.
Ich habe hier mit der Frau Erzit, die hier mit der Frau Erzit gesprochen hat.
Sie haben damit einverstanden.
Ja, klar. Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir.
Sehr gerne.
Aber bevor wir über Ihre Aktuelle Bescheid sprechen,
möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre Personnhedaten aufnehmen.
Wie ist Ihr Name bitte?
Ich heiße Anna Hansen.
Anna Hansen.
Frau Hansen, könnt Sie bitte Ihre Namen langsam buchen?
Ja, ganz einfach.
Anna, A, W, N, A. Hansen, H, A, N, S, E, N.
Okay, Frau Hansen. Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Ich bin am ersten 5.61.
61.
Frau Hansen, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 68.
60.
Und kennen Sie Ihr aktuellen Gewicht?
Mein aktuelles Gewicht ist so um 74 kg, um immer plus, minus, mal ein bisschen mehr, mal ein bisschen weniger.
Okay, 74 kg.
Frau Hansen, was fühlt Sie heute ums? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Wissen Sie, ich werde fast verrückt. Ich habe seit Tagen solche starken Kopfschmerzen,
und zwar so hier an der Seite in der Schlefenregion.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, es klopft ununterbrochen.
Und also morgens geht es immer noch, aber am Abend,
vielleicht hängt es auch an der Wärme, ich weiß es nicht,
aber am Abend habe ich das Gefühl, mir platzt der Schädel.
Ja, und ja, seit heute Morgen ist mir das auch aufgefallen,
dass ich gar nicht so richtig gucken kann, dass ich so Sehstörung habe.
Das flimmert so vor den Augen. Wissen Sie so wie früher, wenn die Fernseher schlecht waren?
Ja, so das Bild kann ich gar nicht feststellen.
Und ich bin total durstig. Ich habe schon ganz viel getrunken heute.
Okay, Frau Hansen, ich möchte ganz kurz Ihre Beschwerden zusammenfassen.
Seit ein paar Tagen leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen, das ist klopfend,
und beidseitig schläfen bereich.
Abends verspülen Sie diese Schmerzen vermehrt.
Seit heute Morgen haben Sie Sehstörungen.
Ja, und das war mir dann doch ein bisschen unheimlich.
Deswegen habe ich gesagt, ich muss jetzt mal zu Ihnen kommen.
Okay, Sie haben die richtige Entscheidung getroffen, Frau Hansen hierher zu kommen.
Könnten Sie diese Kopfschmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sie haben schon klopfend gesagt.
Wie könnten Sie diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala einordnen,
wobei 0 für keine und 10 für unerträglich steht?
Über eine Hälfte auf allen Fälle.
Morgen würde ich sagen noch bei 6, aber abends ist es dann wirklich fast nicht zum Aussaal,
es ist bei 8.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe Ibuprofen eingenommen, aber irgendwie bringt es nicht so richtig.
Wie viel Milligramm Ibuprofen und wie häufig haben Sie eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe am ersten Abend eine 600er genommen, also 3 mal 600 habe ich jetzt genommen.
Okay, aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen versteckt, Frau Hansen oder Verlindert?
Ja, ich denke mal die Nachtruhe hat das so ein bisschen runtergebracht,
deswegen morgens geht es ein bisschen besser.
Aber ja, ich habe den Eindruck, je mehr auf mich einprasselt im Laufe des Tages,
heute bin ich auch gar nicht mehr zur Arbeit gegangen,
gestern war ich noch bei der Arbeit im Vorgestern und je mehr da kamen Informationen
und dann anrufen und angesprechen, hatte ich das Gefühl,
das geht immer höher mit den Schmerzen und wird immer unerträglicher.
Unerträglich, okay.
Frau Hansen, Sie haben schon von Sichtörungen erwähnt.
Können Sie diese Sichtörungen genauer bestellen?
Sie haben schon gesagt, Fliehmann haben sich schwarz vor den Augen oder...
Nee, schwarz eigentlich nicht, aber so dass ich so Unschärfen habe, ja.
Ja, ja.
Sehen Sie doppelt, Frau Hansen?
Nee, doppelt nicht.
Okay, tut Ihre Augen weh, wenn Sie Ihren Augen bewegen?
Wehtun?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Frau Hansen, haben Sie weitere Beschwerden?
Ist Ihnen über, mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Nee, das musste ich zum Glück nicht.
Wie fühlen Sie sich, Frau Hansen, fühlen Sie sich krank
oder haben Sie Fieber, Schützelfrost?
Also, Fieber fühle ich mich nicht, aber ich fühle mich völlig unfähig,
irgendwas zu tun, insofern fühle ich mich schon krank, ja.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie durchstieg sind in Leicester,
oder wie viele Liter trinken Sie täglich?
Also, heute habe ich bestimmt drei Liter getroffen.
Drei Liter täglich.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasser lassen oder mit Schulgang?
Eigentlich nicht.
Müssen Sie in der Nacht häufig zur Toilette?
Manchmal muss ich einmal nach draußen, aber also nicht regelmäßig.
Nicht regelmäßig, manchmal.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Frau Hansen?
Meistens ist es sehr gut.
Heute hätte ich nicht gerne viel gegessen und bin ich so ein bisschen
heute und gestern appetitlos, aber normalerweise schmeckt es mir eigentlich schon gut.
Okay. Haben Sie in Leicester seit Ab oder zu genommen?
Nee, ich ist ziemlich stabil.
Ich muss auch mit dem Essen ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich habe seit ein paar Jahren einen Diabetes festgestellt
und diesen Altersdiabetes.
Und da hat man mir gesagt, ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen mit dem Gewicht
und eben auch mit den Kohlenhydraten.
Wann wurde diese Alterszukrat diagnostiziert, Frau Hansen?
Vor fünf Jahren.
Hat Ihr Blutzucker gut eingestellt?
Kontrollieren Sie regelmäßig?
Ja, also ich gehe eigentlich regelmäßig zu meinem Haus und ich nehme immer
mit Formin morgens und abends.
Wie viel Milligramm wissen Sie, die Dosierung?
Das sind 850er.
850er, okay.
Frau Hansen, Sie haben kein Problem mit Stuhlgang. Sie haben so gesagt, oder?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Okay. Wie sieht Ihr Schlafqualität aus, Frau Hansen? Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, normalerweise kann ich schon gut schlafen.
Manchmal, wenn ich sehr unter Stress bin bei der Arbeit oder so,
dann kann ich schlecht einschlafen.
Aber jetzt die Tage habe ich wirklich nicht gut geschlafen,
weil ich mit so einem dröhnkopf ins Bett gegangen bin.
Dann musste ich mir selber gut zu reden, dass ich jetzt irgendwie einschlafen kann.
Einschlafen, okay.
Frau Hansen, haben Sie weitere Bescheiden?
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Herzrasen, Buruschmerzen,
Engelgefürze oder Atemnot haben?
Nee, so etwas nicht.
Ich weiß, dass ich so ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe, auch schon lange.
Ich messe da auch hin und wieder.
Vor drei Tagen hatte ich, naja, der war da auch schon ein bisschen hoch bei 150 zu 80.
Heute Morgen war der also auch verhältnismäßig hoch mit 180 zu 90.
Ja, Frau Hansen, dann würde ich jetzt die Gespräche unterbrechen
und ganz schnell ihre Brutdruck und andere Vitalparameter messen.
Wenn alles in Ordnung ist, können wir weitersetzen.
Ja, okay, gut, dann machen wir das so.
Ja, jetzt sehr viel fort, Frau Hansen.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Oh, das ist schon, ja, vor acht Jahren hat man das festgestellt.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen Blutdruck?
Ich nehme der Ramipril.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Oh, das ist Ramipril fünf, glaube ich.
Oder nehme ich morgens ein Liter Dessert und eigentlich bin ich damit immer gut klargekommen.
Alles gut, das freut mich.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche andere Alkrankungen abgesehen?
Nein, das langt mir völlig.
Also, dieser Blutdruck und dieser Altersjäger, das macht ja schon keinen Spaß.
Sie haben recht, Frau Hansen, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie weitere Medikamente, Regen, Medikamente oder Bedarfsweise?
Ja, das Iguprofen habe ich halt so da, wenn ich mal irgendwie Schmerzen habe oder so.
Und was mir keinen Ärger mehr macht, da hatte ich vor Jahren mal Probleme.
Da ist die geilen Blase entfernt worden.
Wurde das operiert?
Das ist operativ gemacht worden.
Also, da hat man so einen minimal Eingriff gemacht, also mit einem Leproskop.
Leproskopisch.
Wann wurde diese Operation durchgeführt?
Oh, das ist schon lange her, das ist schon zehn Jahre her.
Ist diese Operation Komplikationslosverlauf?
Ja, das ist erst reingelaufen mit dem kleinen Eingriff, das war richtig gut.
Und danach hatte ich auch keine Beschwerden mehr.
Das freut mich, Frau Hansen.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, tatsächlich. Darf ich kein Penicillin bekommen?
Wieder Penicillin darauf?
Ja, ich habe damit so einen Ausschlag bekommen und Hautrötung.
Und da hat man mir gesagt, dass ich das nicht mehr nehmen soll.
Okay, ich habe mir Notizen gemacht, Frau Hansen.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Frau Hansen, zurück zu Ihrer Beschwerden.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie irgendwo in Ihrem Körper kreben,
Taubheizgefühl oder muskelschwäche haben?
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay, alles gut.
Frau Hansen, wir sind fast durch noch ein paar Fragen.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe tatsächlich, man lebt auch noch nie geraucht.
Ja, das ist gut.
Frau Hansen, natürlich für Ihre Gesundheit.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Ja, hin und wieder mal, wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt.
Ja, wenn wir auf einer Baustelle sind und da wird richtig fest gefeiert,
dann gibt es mal etwas zu trinken.
Oder auch zu Hause, wenn wir Besuch haben und etwas, was ich zum Essen einladen
oder so ein Gardelfest oder so.
Klar, dann wird ein bisschen Alkohol getrunken.
Okay, aber wie viel können wir sagen, Frau Hansen?
Das ist ja nicht jeden Tag Party.
Ja, aber im Sommer trinkt man schon abends gerne mal ein Bier auf der Terrasse
oder so und im Winter eher mal ein Glas Wein.
Also vielleicht so zwei Flaschen Bier in der Woche oder zwei Gläser Wein in der Woche.
Okay, das ist gut.
Frau Hansen, rutinärmäßig muss ich fragen, bitte nehmen Sie sich nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit anderen Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, nee, nee, also Drogen, da kenne ich mich überhaupt nicht mit aus.
Hab ich auch nicht vor.
Das habe ich erwartet, Frau Hansen.
Frau Hansen, sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Nein, mein Vater, der ist ganz früh gestorben.
Der hat unter Tage gearbeitet und der hat eine Staublunge.
Und da ist er nur 45 Jahre alt geworden.
Der ist also wirklich sehr, sehr früh gestorben.
Und meine Mutter, die lebt noch, die hat sich eigentlich ganz gut gehalten.
Die hat nur bisschen Knieprobleme.
Knieprobleme.
Mein hat sich als Beileid Frau Hansen für Ihre, für die Verlust von Ihrem Vater.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, wir waren eine große Familie.
Ich hatte vier Geschwester und eine ist tatsächlich auch schon mit 60 am Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Die ist wirklich auch nicht alt geworden.
Mein hat sich als Beileid auch Frau Hansen, das muss schwer sein.
Die anderen Geschwester?
Die anderen haben nichts. Die sind alle fit, wie sonst was.
Okay, alles gut.
Frau Hansen, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Töchter.
Die sind aber schon so gut wie aus dem Haus.
Die sind erwachsen.
Und sie sind gesund, ich hoffe.
Ja, die sind gesund.
Das ist gut.
Frau Hansen, Sie haben schon von Ihrer Arbeit erwähnt.
Was ist Ihre Form?
Ich bin Buchhalterin in unserer Tischlerei.
Mein Mann hat eine eigene Tischlerei.
Und ich mache für die Firma die Buchhaltung.
Das geht manchmal ein bisschen zackig zu, wenn wir Fristen haben,
wenn irgendetwas schnell gehen muss,
wenn die Sachen fürs Finanzamt hat, die sein müssen.
Ja, da hat man auch schon mal ein bisschen Stress.
Oder wenn irgendwelche Kunden nicht bezahlen
und man dahinter herhaken muss,
das sind alles so Sachen, die nicht so schön sind.
Ja, das kann ich gut verstehen, Frau Hansen.
Das muss schwer.
Drehen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Das würde ich jetzt nicht gerade sagen.
Manchmal gehen wir abends noch eine Runde um den Block.
Im Winter waren wir auch schon mal schielaufen,
aber das haben wir eigentlich jetzt schon längere Jahre nicht mehr gemacht.
Manchmal fahre ich, bei gutem Wetter fahre ich auch mal mit dem Fahrrad,
aber so sportlich in dem eigentlichen Sinne ist das nicht.
Okay, Frau Hansen, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Geimpft? Sie meinen gegen Covid?
Ja, da bin ich klar, da bin ich dreimal geimpft. Viermal sogar.
Viermal.
Ach, wichtig.
Frau Hansen, sind Sie in den nächsten sechs Monaten irgendwo hin gereist?
Ich meine, ins Ausland.
Ins Ausland?
Wir waren mal in Holland, in den Niederlanden
und wir waren mal in Österreich, aber also nix exotisches.
Okay, nichts exotisches.
Frau Hansen, meinerseits habe ich alle Fragen gestellt.
Falls Ihnen noch etwas ein oder haben, Sie fragen an mich?
Ich will jetzt natürlich nur wissen,
was man gegen diese Wahnsinn Kopfschmerzen machen kann.
Ja, Frau Hansen, jetzt ist es natürlich zu früh, eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Aber nach Ihrer Angabe habe ich eine Vermutung,
dass Ihre Blutdruck und Blutzucker nicht gut eingestellt ist.
Ihre Blutdruck war gestern ein bisschen hoch.
Wir haben schon hier gemessen, das war ein bisschen über normalen Grenzen.
Aber um zu bestätigen, brauchen wir natürlich weitere Untersuchungen.
Jetzt möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und ein paar Laborwerte bestimmen.
Ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt Ihren Fall besprechen.
Und dann sehen wir mal, wie es weitergeht.
Okay, gut. Dankeschön.
Ja, danke schön.
Das ist gut.
Das war gut, ja.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch eine Frage?
Ich glaube, sie hat sehr vollständig gefragt.
Ich kann mir fast nicht vorstellen, dass auch irgendwas übrig ist.
Und aus 10 Minuten ist sehr, sehr gut.
Ja, wir waren echt schnell.
Wobei, das ist jetzt auch nicht so ein wahnsinnig komplizierter Fall.
Aber es ist ein typischer Düsseldorfer.
Keine Fragen.
Alles erstüpfend abgegrast.
Wenn wir erst mal die Frage anfangen.
Bestimmt, oder? Rabia?
Ja, wir können anfangen.
Aber ich werde ein Teil für mich.
Ja, mit genauso gut.
Bitte schön.
Ja, schönen guten Abend Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Darf ich kurz vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Wer haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, die 63-jährige Patientin, Frau Anna Hansen.
Sie ist 1,61 m groß und 74 kg schwer.
Sie stellt sich heute wegen seit ein paar Tagen
Kopfschmerzen
und
Zeichterungen vor.
Die Kopfschmerzen beschreiben sie
Klopfen,
beidseitig in temporale Bereiche.
Schmerzintensität sei morgens 6 von
10 auf einer Schmerzskala
und abends 8 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala auf.
Das Medikament Ibuprofen,
600 mg dreimal,
für keine Linderung herbei.
Zusätzlich klackte sie über Zeichterungen
seit heute Morgen.
Sie beschreibt die Beschwerden
und Herrscherfte sehen.
Und scharfes Sehen.
Fragen nach doppelt sehen
wurde verneid.
Zu den weiteren Beschwerden
gehören
Leistungsfähigkeit,
nein, verminderte Leistungsfähigkeit.
Apetitlosigkeit, aber Schmerzbedingte, Schlafstörung und Nectarie, einmal pro Nacht und
die Schmerzbedingte durch empfinden. Sie trinken drei Liter täglich.
Immer oder heute nur?
Eigentlich, sie hat seit letzten Zeiten, hat sie...
In der letzten Zeit, okay.
Ja, an der Vorerkrankung leidet sie vor fünf Jahren Diabetes mellitus und vor acht Jahren Artilielle
Hypertonie, aber vor drei Tagen hat ihre Blutdruck gemessen und das war 186,90.
Deswegen habe ich mein Gespräch unterberichtet und unterbrochen und die Teilfrau meister gemessen.
Blutdruck war ein bisschen erhöht, aber nach der Vorstellung werde ich während der Untersuchung
das war komplikationslos und die ist allergisch auf Penicillin, die hat Penicillin-Allergie,
äußert sich mit Egber und Haufbeschwerden.
Frau Hansen ist nicht raucherin, Drogen von Zumbur der Verneins, sie trinkt ein, zwei
Flaschen Bier oder ein Glas Weih, Provohe zur familienanamnästisch.
Sie hat seit der Königin Probleme bekannt und ihr Vater ist mit 45 Jahren an Phenomokonios gestorben.
Sie hatte vier Geschwester, aber eine Schwester ist mit 80 Jahren an Neocard in Phenomokonios gestorben.
Mit 80? Nein, 60.
Frau Hansen ist verheiratet, habe zwei gesünderte Öfter, sie ist Buchhalterin vom Beruf, aber habe
Stress bei der Arbeit, sie treibt keine regelmäßigen Sport, ihr ihm fast sei vollständig und Reise
an Amnese war leer.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Aufgrund der anamnästischen Angaben habe ich eine Vermutung, eine Entgleitung von Diabetes mellitus
und auch Arterial-Lechipaltonen.
Differenzial-diagnostisch kann ich, ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht Migraine oder was noch.
Worstcase?
Ich habe die Anamnästchen, meine ich.
Was wäre schlimmstenfalls, was könnte Sie schlimmstenfalls noch haben?
Vielleicht eine Humor oder eine Hirnblutung.
Wobei dafür sind die Symptome natürlich noch nicht so richtig dramatisch.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Für die zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich die Patientin körperlich untersuchen, wie Teilkörmester
oder Meta haben wir schon gemessen, eine e-Karage-Stattung.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, was achten Sie vom Aspekt her?
Neurologische Untersuchung ist wichtig für die Patientin.
Und im Labo würde ich folgendes überprüfen,
überprüfen,
Okay. Und ja, dann werden wir schauen, dass bei ihren Befunden rauskommt. Halten
Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über die Patientin und dann schauen wir nachher,
würden Sie sagen, Sie muss die Stationär aufgenommen werden?
Ja, ich würde die Patientin Stationär aufnehmen und Monitor anschließen.
Und die Philosophie zuvor mit Elektrolyten ist...
Ja, das wäre sicherlich vernünftig. Gut, dann sehen wir uns nachher vielleicht noch
beim Weitervisit. Alles klar. Gut. Also tschüss. Wunderbar.
Ich habe ein bisschen was zu meckern. Ein bisschen was habe ich noch. Es gibt
Beoptimierung. Ja, ein Klassiker im Gespräch mit der Patientin.
Ich werde Sie erst körperlich untersuchen. Dann ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Oh, bitte! Sag nicht so was. Ja, also dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Das wird immer wieder gern genommen. Ja. Und ja, diese hohen Trinkmengen hat Sie eigentlich gesagt,
seit heute Morgen hat sie das Augenflimmern und den Stapendurst.
Und dann hast du gefragt, wie viel hat sie getrunken? Und dann hat sie gesagt,
drei Liter habe ich bestimmt schon getrunken. Also sie trinkt es nicht regelmäßig so viel.
Okay. Ja. Und dann hast du mir noch einen Gefallen getan, dass ich dann noch mal darauf hinweisen kann.
Vor Erkrankungen. Sie hat vor fünf Jahren Diabetes mellitus. Nein, sie hat seit fünf Jahren Diabetes mellitus.
Ich habe es nicht gelesen, der betrifft mich. Und sie hat seit acht Jahren Hypertonie.
Ja, also vor zehn Jahren ist die geilen OP gewesen. Abgeschlossenes Ereignis.
Aber der Diabetes und der Blutoschruf sind diagnostiziert und bestehen, seit weiter.
Es gilt für alle, wird immer wieder gerne genommen, dass man das verwechselt.
Und es ist irreführend. Es sind wirklich, es ist eine andere Aussage.
Man kann sagen, vor zehn Jahren oder vor fünf Jahren ist irgendwas diagnostiziert worden.
Aber sie hat seit fünf Jahren den Typ II Diabetes.
Ja, das eigentlich nur nochmal, um die Aufmerksamkeit nochmal auf die Feinheiten zu legen.
Ansonsten war es sprachlich eigentlich wunderbar. Wir konnten uns sehr gut verständigen.
Du hast komplett nachgefragt und hast komplett wiedergegeben.
Ich glaube, viel besser kann man es wirklich nicht machen.
Ich hoffe, Ihnen kann ich da ab.
Ja, ich sage mal so, hoffentlich hast du richtig nette Prüfer.
Es gibt Leute, die erzählen, dass sie eine ganz entspannte Prüfungssituation hatten.
Dr. Gönn ist mit es nicht glauben, aber es gibt ja andere.